yes okay cool so once again for the
recording uh welcome to the computer
vision study group in August today we
will talk about segment anything so
that's the paper probably a lot of
people have heard about because it just
made some waves when it came out and it
only came out in April for me it felt
like oh it's been there for so long but
oh it's four months which maybe machine
learning time is long um but yeah
came out in April from MAA
AI um and yeah as always I'd like to put
a little theme to my presentations and
start with an intro story so I I like to
come up with some stories um that are
more or less related to the topic and
yeah today's theme is
oh I think it h kind of neon neon
Punk uh um ninja style I would say and
yeah we start with the story and then we
dive into the
paper so it is a warm summer night in
sex city where the buildings grow High
and the streets never
sleep uh for the story I created some
images as you see uh with generative AI
of course I used the stable or the sdxl
model so the new one from stability
AI is pretty
good um yeah and we go on with the story
so for months now Clan Wars have been
shaking the city every day three big
families are competing for
Supremacy the micro Clan having found
new Strength new allies and new ideas
they want to rule the
city the elok clan having been ahead of
the other four long time the things are
changing
recently The Meta Clan it has seen
better days with more money nevertheless
they keep coming up with
Innovations a key Concept in sex City's
Urban Warfare is height and attack for
which all clans have their own ninja
forces to avoid these sneak attacks the
glans introduced Special Forces to
Monitor and segment the
environment the segmentation measures
were good but rather limited until
recently when the meta Clan
introduced
Sam she's a result of many months of
training in meta's special program to
segment
anything her abilities allowed her to do
the work of many different segmentors by
herself but even more important ly she
was able to pass on her skills and
enable others to achieve great
things the streets of sex city still are
a battlefield Sam won't be able to
change that but her power enter
disciples are to have a big impact in
this
city and that's
it that's the end of the story it was a
rather short story this time um because
I focused bit more on like this this
paper part because I feel like there's
so much stuff in the paper actually it
could have been two papers um yeah
because in this paper you not only have
this model like the segment anything
model but also they describe the whole
data set and how they made the data set
and everything um I think a lot of
researchers would have just really made
it into two papers because you could
easily do that um but yeah they decided
not to so they have a long appendix and
yeah a lot of information in their paper
but here in the presentation today I
will try to focus on the model a bit
more than on like the data
set yeah because I mean the data set is
interesting very
interesting um but the model is harder
to understand I would say and and yeah I
think that's what what we're trying to
do here in the CV study group is mainly
understanding stuff um and if you feel
like it you can always have a look at
most data set statistics yourself like
where are all the images from or in
which countries or whatever um so
yeah okay I've talked a bit about the
paper already um so let's first have a
look actually at image segmentation
right so what what is like image
segmentation um so for me when I hear
image segmentation there's always stuff
like this it comes to my mind so we have
like an an original image over
here uh and then we have a segmentation
map and in the segmentation map you can
see different colors right in this case
it's like a semantic segmentation map so
you have um things that are the same
class basically in the same color for
example the cars are this greenish and
the crown somewhat I don't know what you
call it Tois Tois maybe the buildings
are pink and the sky is red right so
it's like a semantic segmentation map um
so for me that's yeah like the most
natural thing when I think about image
segmentation then you often see this is
overlays as well right like here and you
can see aha okay here we have our cars
and this Sky um yeah but actually there
are
like different kinds of image
segmentation right so what I talked
about now already is the semantic
segmentation where we have like yeah
these um
Parts segmented by the classes they
belong to and the important thing about
semantic segmentation is that like the
whole image is covered so every pixel
has some value assigned right so there's
no pixel that is like yeah well nothing
so everything is
something because in contrast to that
there is instant segmentation where you
don't need to have the whole image
assigned somehow and we actually focus
more on instances of objects right for
example here again the cars right so
every car has a different color and we
we don't care about buildings about
crown or about the sky um in instance
segmentation it's really about finding
single instances of
things and then there's a pen optic
segmentation um actually for a long time
I thought this was called instant
semantic segmentation but I learned it's
panoptic segmentation which is just
really a combination of of both um very
we try to cover or where we do cover the
whole image uh but we try
to detect or segment as many instances
as possible of these different classes
we have right so panoptic segmentation
is just really the combination of the
form and
two and yeah may be the most helpful but
can also be the most difficult to uh
yeah to get to
actually so yeah one big problem now is
like what if you want to detect new
classes for segmentation right segment
new classes it should actually be for
example like signs or Billboards or or
something like that so what we will have
to do
is annotate it right so we have to go to
our data sets and then have to get up
our labeling tool probably uh sit in
front of our computer or whatever and
then start labeling these pixels cuz
it's like the hardest part I think for
segmentation data set is really just
labeling
everything because it's it's like this
dense task where we really yeah care
about each pixel right like for object
detection often you just have bounding
boxes so you draw a bonding box here
bonding box there bonding box there and
it's all good but for this pixel stuff
you even want yeah the best accuracy
actually right because then you feel
like OKAY model can learn best when it's
best accuracy so it's a lot of work to
actually create a data set for semantic
segmentation um so so the question may
arise okay there's so much work so much
money that goes into it in the end isn't
there like a better way so are there
Solutions
um actually this slide mainly exists
because of the image um the image kind
of happened when I played around with
SXL model and was okay it's so cool it
just has to be in the presentation so
yeah Solutions question
mark and one solution that
comes to mind um is the
socalled zero shot image segmentation
right so what we do here is like we have
an image and then we just say billboard
signs and the model be give this prompt
to basically so this is like our text
prompt right billboard signs and the
model can give us the mask with the
Billboards and signs without any further
additional training data so that's what
zero shot means right basically we think
it has never seen Billboards or
signs um and then yeah it can segment it
any way because it has learned so much
about like the nature of it um yeah that
it can just do it that's a zero short
image segmentation and that what
makes um Sam so outstanding because it
is a way to
yeah leverage zero shot image
segmentation with
prompts and what these prompts can be
and the whole architecture is the next
slide oh was yeah so let's have a look
at like how can Sam do this whole thing
how do they get to these zero shot
capabilities and how can they do that so
at the start of the whole architecture
there's an image encoder right there you
give your image in there and it gives
you a representation of the image so
tokens
embeddings whatever you want to call it
and this is only done once so for
example when you're in their official
two or whatever on their project page
and you upload an image then they do
this once this image encoder thing right
they just get your image send it to the
encoder and then they save the
embeddings um for further stuff so not
every time you you're trying to segment
something in the image say do the image
encoding step again that is only done
once right in the beginning and then the
the embeddings are there because your
image does not change unless you upload
a new one right U so the next step would
be that we can add a mask as a prompt
actually so the mask goes through some
convolutional layers uh to get it in the
same dimensions as the image embeddings
and then it just gets added
basically but there are other proms we
can use as well so we can just put in
points right you can say Okay want here
here here or we can just use a bounding
box as a prompt or a text and then those
go through a prompt
encoder
actually and then the prompt encoder
embeddings or the prompt embeddings are
then fed to a mask decoder where also
the image
embeddings and The Mask if it
exists um go in okay and in the end we
get a mask out right so that's
like the
architecture now you might wonder like
me okay that's good but what what is in
the prompt encoder and The Mask decoder
and maybe even the image encoder right
um and after say the paper in the main
part is a bit short on that so they put
most of the explanation in the appendix
probably do have more space in the main
part for data set stuff but yeah if if
you want to read about that you have to
go to the appendix and I did that right
so um let's have a look and start with
the image encoder because it is actually
at the start and the symbols one of the
encoder decoder things
here so yeah for the image coder of
course we have an image right and we
give that to a pre-trained um Vision
Transformer they say they use one uh
that is strained with the um mask Auto
encoder
stuff so the the my which basically just
helps um getting a better quality even
with fewer
images and then they get the output of
that and feed into some convolutional
networks to in the end get to the
embeddings they want so yeah it's not
much magic in there so the vid that's
actually the the compute heaviest part I
would even say in the architecture is
this this image thing here because what
they also say like in their architecture
they focus
on uh on speed mainly so that this whole
Sam segment anything model can even run
in in a browser and that's they say okay
this this first part yeah that's a bit
compute heavy but we only do it once and
then um you can prompt
whatever so yeah here we get our image
embeddings and the
next step is a prompt encoder which is a
bit more
complicated um and I have to had to read
it a few times actually to really like
understand
it um and I'm still not sure if I
completely understood it even after
looking at code and
everything because it was it is a bit
strange at points so here it say it's
sparse prompt encoder because they say
okay these are the sparse prompts and
when you put it in a mask it's a dense
prompt um so this is The Spar prompt
encoder
basically um and we start with like
these points up here and the the
bounding
boxes and they get fed
into they get fed to but um we first
create positional embeddings from them
right so we get our points which are
somewhere in our coordinate frame in the
original
image and from the bounding boxes we
take the upper left and lower right
corner and we create the positional
embeddings from them it's actually the
absolute
cidal positional
embeddings if you know some stuff about
position edings I don't know too much
about it but um yeah they are absolute
cidal positional embeddings here they
are
creating and then we take these
embeddings like here are our position
embeddings these ones like the four ones
from the four
points and then depending on where the
point is um we add to it a background or
a for Crown token like learnable
embeddings as well here
um yeah so background tokens get added
to the point that are not part of the
ground rules but are part of the
prediction right so basically false
positives and foreground ones are the
ones where the ground RS and the
prediction
overlap so true positives right false
positive true
positive okay for the bounding box it's
bit simpler um just get there one for
top left and and one for lower right
that you add as well like these are
separate position embeddings you add
them and for the text encoder they just
take the clip text encoder actually so
clip is an other model a multimod model
that exists that has a text and an image
encoder and they just say oh yeah we
just use basically clip text encoder and
send our text in there and in the end
what we get are our prompt tokens or
prompt embeddings
out here right so maybe to say it now
this this whole part with the the text
is a bit strange because they talk about
it a lot in the
paper but in their released version
there's no no hint of it right so they
say yeah yeah okay for the text you can
do it like this and that and um it even
needs a bit of a different training
strategy um but yeah they never really
released something something that can
use text out of the box so there are
there are some more projects that can do
that but from meta themselves there's to
this date no model that can just take
text in so basically the prompts are
mostly um points or
boxes yep okay so that was the prompt
encoder now we get to the mask
decoder which is I feel like the most
complicated thing and you can see here
we have our image edings right the green
ones if you remember green is image
embeddings then we have our token
embeddings down here the blue ones and
what we do is weate another
token which is this purple one and that
is a class token so if you're familiar
with Transformers and stuff like bird or
like in general class tokens are often
used to yeah to be the output in the end
right so when you want to classify
something with a WID or whatever usually
in the end you get the class token out
and then you can say okay this is like a
duck or a cat um and it's similar here
because the glass token in the end is
used uh to really create the mask and
yeah so basically it's it's the mask
output token you could
say okay and all these well you five
tokens you could say the number can be
different right depending on how many
prompts you have like if you use
six uh points as promts you have like
six of these and yeah so you first feed
these prompt tokens here into the
decoder block and the first step is a
self attention so basically uh yeah it
just helps in in getting these tokens
more context aware about each
other and the next step is a cross
attention where the goal is to actually
help the these tokens and the prom
tokens become more aware of the image
embeddings right
so basically yeah in the paper they they
write it as a cross attention from
prompt tokens to image embeddings that's
why I
put this Arrow here um but maybe I I
will think about it the other way
because actually the the image
embeddings teach the prompt
embeddings about their information right
oh next step is that we feed our prom
tokens into an MTI layer
perceptron thingy just for some
dimensionality things and then in the
last step of the decoder block we
actually go the other way around with
the cross attention so
that um the image tokens get some
information from the prom tokens right
so this way we have like a yeah two-way
cross attention here well two times one
way you could say um yeah once in this
direction once in this direction so in
the end these tokens are somewhat
connected and know about the information
from the other
tokens and we do this decoder block just
two times so it just have like two
layers quite a small decoder but as I
already mentioned they try to focus on
speed and that yeah that helps just
having two
layers okay then so after these two
layers they take the image embeddings
and feed them through some convolutions
to upscale them a bit again because they
will downscale in the image encoder and
now they want to up scale it again they
used some convolutions for it um and
then again they have a cross detention
here where for the last time basically
the prompt tokens learn a bit about the
image
tokens and then the class token which I
talked about before right gets fed to a
multilayer percep Ron again and then the
output from here goes here and with a
DOT product you combine the image
embeddings and the output mask
embeddings basically and then you get
your mask out that that's the mask
decoder it's a bit of a long way in the
end um and you might have some
questions uh I understand that's
something I had to look at a long time
and always go to the paper then try to
try to figure it out myself and yeah
it's just well not that easy but also
not that highly complicated I would say
but now there's one problem actually
with masks where they say in the paper
Okay um yeah that's what happens when
you use Point prompts and that's mask
ambiguity I hope I pronounced it
correctly um that means that when I put
a prompt Point here right on on this cap
um what do I mean what do I want to get
out as a mask as a human right what what
was my intention of getting do I want
like only this this cap here or do I
want to get the whole tire or wheel or
do I want to get the whole car right and
that's a problem um that they were
facing apparently especially during
validation I guess because I mean I
could mean all three of these things
right so most likely for me would be not
the whole car maybe the whole wheel
probably the whole
wheel um but yeah this mask ambiguity
thing is something they
tackled by going to the m decoder again
right you see here our class token and
they actually use three class tokens
here okay so they they not just have
like one output mask but they say okay
we just take three output masks and so
three was like the The Sweet Spot for
them they tried different numbers
and yeah they say Okay three mostly is
the best thing um because they have like
subp part part and hole or something as
you can also see here right like this
would be like subpart part and
Hole uh yeah and that's covered with
these three output
tokens so in the end um these things
here are three tokens right and then you
get masks out and not just a mask
um and what they also do is that they
have token in here that is just used in
the end to give us the intersection over
Union um scores of these masks that we
then get out in the end here um yeah and
why they need these scores I will tell
you later it's some especially for
validation and testing
stuff
uh okay but that is like the image of
the Mask decoder what you see here now
is like the the whole mask
decoder and
yeah let's jump to the next one which is
the training procedure right because you
might ask yourself okay how the hell do
they train this now um I mean the task
they are tackling they call it prompt
based SE
segmentation so of course the first
thing is you need a ground Ru ground Ru
mask for example for this car here then
you need a prompt prompt is this
point and then you get a prediction
right ground truth
prediction okay so now you have these
two things Crown truth and
prediction and you can take both of them
and create the intersection over Union
right that is like
the uh yeah the base
uh metric for most segmentation tasks so
you have like the overlap of both of
these masks and the union of both of
these masks right so like the whole
thing they cover if you just yeah put
them on top of each other you get like
the union and the overlap is the area
that is present in in both of these
masks and resist over section over
Union they then use two losses actually
the focal loss and a dice loss which is
also F1 loss Dice and F1 I learned are
the same I hope I learned it
correctly um yeah and oh it is really
similar to in this simple intersection
over a union but oh a bit
different um and the focal loss mainly
helps us focus on uh hard examples Right
Stuff where where it fails uh bigger or
more often and then they combine these
two losses uh linear linearly in the end
um and they say they have it in a ratio
of 20 to1 so they put some some weights
on
it yeah and it's just so the focal loss
is way more important than the dice loss
in the end for their training okay so
that is what they do in in one iteration
basically when they prompted it but
there's more because they prompted it a
bit more often right so for each mask
they say like okay uh we did the first
one the initial one and then we do eight
more of these prompts in the areas where
it is quite uncertain right or where is
wrong or where is uncertain so we we put
some more prompts there so that that's
eight more so in total you can say
there's there's nine prompts now and
then they also saying we find out it
helps if we just run it two times
without adding any
any prompt so they just keep it at like
seven points prompt it again and then
they add another Point um yeah and they
say yeah this keeping the the same
amount of proms is
um mainly helping when you do it in the
end once and somewhere in between
somewhere in between doesn't really
matter apparently when you do it but the
one in the end does matter for some
reason there's always these experiments
I find quite interesting like how did
they find that out how many times did
they experiment with that right but yeah
so that's um kind of what they say is
helping so in the end you have um 11
times that you go through the whole loss
thing and every time you actually get
out three masks right as I showed before
for this ambiguity problem and they only
back propagate the loss for the like the
the smallest intersection over Union
right so they don't do it for all three
mask but they just take like the the
smallest insection of a union so the
masket does best and they use that for
back propagation
then yeah okay that's how they train it
basically and here are some results of
it so they did validate it on 23 data
sets and they mainly compared it here to
this other model this ritm model that is
also doing like prompt or like Point
based uh
segmenting and here they say okay they
used one Center Point here that means
they just took like the center of the
ground Cruise mask and then they used
that for prompting their model and they
are doing really well on a lot of um
these data sets so mostly better than
the itm model but there are also some
where they do
worse and they also introduce this
Oracle thing here um so they say yeah we
also have our Oracle prompt here some
Oracle and Oracle here also is like
these dots right these these dashed
lines and the Oracle is when they're
actually looking at their intersection
over Union
scores and take the
best mask um yeah the best mask
according to this intersection of a
union scores because apparently
sometimes when you prompt the model it
does not automatically give you like the
best mask that would fit the crown TRS
right again this ambiguity problem that
you can get any of these three where the
model things are is actually the best
one right now but then when you go back
and compare to the crown truth it was
not the best of the three masks so for
this Oracle they say okay we actually
take what would be the best of the three
masks so it's a bit of well I don't know
if you can call it cheating but it's um
yeah like they say okay if we would take
the best of these masks then we would be
here here here and here right then they
would always be better but um in reality
they are not so yeah they just wanted to
prove I think that they can be better
than the other
thing um what's interesting is here that
they say okay that's like the the
machine the automatic validation but we
also want to let humans rate it right so
let humans have a look at it and there
they say okay when humans look at our
mask we are always better than the
ritm um for these data sets
here uh
yeah and on here what we have here here
there are more models actually the
simple click and focer click which get
better when they have more points so the
simple click and focal click are not
designed to be like one point segmenters
but they're more yeah focus on having
more points to help them segment and
yeah here they also say okay Sam is way
better when we do it like with just a
few points um in the end when there are
more points than the other ones are
pretty good as well all
right and here yeah here's the center
points so always pointed are in the
center and random
points
similar okay so that's like the segment
anything model with results and now we
have a short look on the data set
stuff because as I said they also
release the data set right with the
whole segment anything model and they
have this data set with like 11 million
images with 1.1 billion masks it's
really a big data
set and they also talk about how they
collected that actually so they used
three stages the first one is the
assisted manual stage second one the
semi-automatic stage and the third one
the fully automatic
stage so at the first stage we just go
through the stages now because I think
it's pretty interesting um because
labeling stuff or even using Sam to
label your own data is like one of the
main yeah main things I would see use
for Sam Actually in labeling my data or
my company's data right just making it
easier for me not having to sit in front
of the computer for like weeks just to
get some segmentation
data so how they did it how they created
this huge data set for them is um in the
first stage they have this model
assisted thing so they have an
image uh they give that to a
human the human says okay here I I put
some prompt in I put here here here here
here um there should be some some object
right uh and then give that to the the
first version basically of of the Sam
model and Sam gives us some some masks
you give that back to the human the
human can say Okay um I refined this
mask here and this mask here and this
mask
there uh and then add that to annotate
data set and then from time to time they
retrain Sam on this data set even still
in in this first stage of model assisted
manual thingy they retrain it somewhere
in between I think they don't say how
long the stages lasted but I can imagine
this stage was like the longest stage
because it has a lot of human
interaction um and yeah it probably
takes some time so they just yeah
retrain them to get better
results in between so the second stage
uh it's a semi-automatic stage so we
still have the human have an
image and we give the image again to a s
and
then what they did is that they used
like the data from the last stage and
trained an object detection model on
this data already and then they use this
object detection model to create prompts
for Sam in this stage so to get better
initial results basically without a
human having to prompt
anything and so then yeah you get this
mask again give this to a human human
says uh okay here you can do better
there and there and there and then again
you have the annotate data set and then
from time to time they retrain um the
same model
right so yeah
pretty similar actually just less human
interaction and in the last stage the
fully automatic stage um there's no
human anymore because they said like
yeah at this point we had a lot of stuff
figured out like the mask and bigy thing
and then we got way better actually and
we didn't need a human anymore so they
just take um the image give it to give
it to the Sam model again then they
create a git of 32 * 32 um dots to
prompt
it right and then they get a lot of
masks out of
it and then they have like these these
three key concepts for masks to keep
them or to dismiss them and it's like
confidence stability and non- maximum
suppression and with this these three
concepts in the end they get their fully
annotated fully but yeah they annotated
data set uh yeah which in the end has 11
million images and
1.1 billion masks which is a
lot um
yeah right but one thing maybe about the
whole data set creation and everything
what bothers me about the paper is a bit
so they do their best to talk a bit
about ethics and like responsible AI in
terms of hey so we created our data set
and we checked the biases so they tried
to include a lot of images from a lot of
different settings and
countries and so forth um but I really
wonder about actually the humans that
were involved in this whole data
creation thing right because they never
talk about like the humans that are uh
used here um yeah I'm also a bit
concerned about this like low wage uh
yeah data annotating
people so that's something I would have
wished some information on from MAA but
maybe well they didn't want to put it in
there I don't
know yeah that's just my my little
critic about this data set
stuff so right in the beginning in the
story I already mentioned that um like
one big advantage of Sam is that it
actually can help other projects right
to grow and it was amazing to see like
right after it came out there was so
many ideas from people and and many
things that happened and I just put in
um two GitHub resources here basically
they are pretty similar so when you open
it I open it
somewhere
or
not um you will just get to get up page
oh yeah now now I opened it four times
of course and there's just a long list
of projects that are leveraging the s
model in some way
right so if my computer is not dying now
I can show
you ah here we
go so it's called awesome segment
anything actually there a lot of reos
that are called something with awesome
segment anything or or aome segment I
don't know um but yeah this is one of
the ones with the most stars so I just
chose that
one and yeah you can see there's a lot
of stuff in here like base papers base
model papers so that's basically papers
that are good to understand as well for
the segment
anything part um derivative
papers and image meting reporting
project yeah that's where I wanted to go
right so I think one of the best
projects actually is crowned segment
anything here because that actually yeah
lets you use text
proms um so when you yeah want to use
really like these text proms that they
prom is in the paper but they don't
deliver in the code then crowned segment
anything is a good thing to go to
because it can do
that and yeah it's basically using this
crowning dyo thing together with segment
anything and then it yeah is pretty good
I have to
say but there are other projects um
there's stuff
like this magic copy which is a Chrome
extension that lets you just do the
foreground background segmentation
pretty
well
and yeah there's also mobile Sam
somewhere and Fast Sam which try to
shrink the whole thing even more so you
can use it on uh less powerful
devices but yeah you can just scroll
through that yourself if you want to um
but yeah if you want to use it in code
yourself right segment anything it's
also available in the Transformers
library from huging face right so as we
on hugging face Discord here I suppose
everyone knows hugging face um yeah and
I just link the official docs here and
there's Al some example notebooks from
NE over
here where you can see how to use it so
here's two one is like fine-tune Sam on
a custom data set and one is run the
inference with met Sam which is a
derivative of the original Sam model and
you can have a short look at that just
to give you a feeling of how
to maybe use the S model with
Transformers Library so we yeah import
everything torch and Transformers so you
can import the Sam model and the S
processor and then we instantiate both
of them here um we give like the huging
face up for the model uh to the the
address this is rang laab mm with base
okay so it's a med Sam not the original
Sam and then you can load a data set for
example the breast conso data set here
from from
needs and yeah you can take any image
out of the data set so here he takes
this image he loads the image loads the
the CR through mask basically so you can
see it
here and yeah in the next
steps um he creates a box prompt hello
can you hear me oh yeah I can hear now
yeah uh sorry I can see your screen oh
wait a second
here it is
right can you see it
now uh yeah thank you okay cool thank
you thanks for telling me um yeah so you
get actually the the crown Tru thing
here and from this Crown Tru mask he
creates a a box
prompt so he just adds some some noise
basically to it to not have like really
close but have like a bit of space
around use this rent in right so yeah
just creates the Box around it and then
us it this uses this one as input box
for the Sam
model so you can see the box right it's
a bit bigger than the original thing
actually and then yeah you can use this
uh you can call the processor put the
image in and the input
boxes and yeah in the end you can get it
out again and
visualize so it's
actually I I feel like the the actual
part of the model is is quite small but
there's a lot of things to do around
like yeah creating the box and I mean up
here Neil just did a lot of code for uh
making it visible like the image and the
ground TOS mask so um in total the code
is quite small that you really really
need when you don't want to visualize
everything thing right just when you
want to make it as visual as need here
oh it gets a bit
longer but yeah I would say say
absolutely feel free to check out his
notebooks they are pretty good also the
one for like the custom data set
training um which might also be really
interesting for a lot of people but it's
even longer so I don't want to go
through it all here
yeah so
that is it for now I would say wait I
have some thank you slide here thank
you uh yeah do you have any questions
right
now uh I have one question uh so uh it's
about fine tuning Sam the the Sam model
was trained with prompts or boxes and
um and the losses but we need the prompt
so in in case of fine tuning do we need
to like for example metsa manually label
the the pieces we want in the
image
um what do you exactly mean by the
pieces do you mean the segments
or yes for example uh you need for
example to to point the foreground
background or
boxes and do we need for example if we
have an x-ray
uh like kidney we have to box the kidney
to and then do the the training Loop
okay something else so now we do
actually have a look at this fine tuning
data set because I have to say that one
thing I I didn't look into myself very
deeply but maybe we can do it together
now because I mean we have the thing
here
anyway
um so we have our Crown Tru mask some
data set blah blah blah bounding
box oh yeah okay he uses bounding box
prompt then prepares
everything okay so here he takes svit
base model right so the original one
from Facebook
basically and uses this some data set
here
so it looks like he is using
yeah so he's using box prompts right as
before I guess he created these box
prompts um from the crru masks with some
some noise to it so when you have
your your data set and you do have some
Crown to mask already you can just
create this bounding box around this
mask like he did before it's the same
here right some some noise to it and
then use these
boxes um yeah as a prompt basically for
Sam to find unit as far as I can see
here that's what's
happening
okay thanks yeah no
problem
okay any more
questions if not that is
it and thank you for attending and have
a good day or night or whatever time it
is at your place